opportunité incroyable apparemment
beaucoup de fébrilité ça va être le fun
je pense ça marche je vois comme une
expérience du père positive j'ai quand
même de nombreux amateurs de football
seront sans doute derrière les chiefs de
kansas city cette fin de semaine et du
québécois le rang du vernis tardif de
mont-saint-hilaire le joueur de 28 ans 6
pieds 5 pouces 321 une livre rapportage
de protéger son quart arrière le rendre
vernis tardif qui est diplômé de
médecine de l'université mcgill avec
nous ray lalonde analystes et experts du
marché du sport vont soit ray lalonde
c'est tout un événement annuel
incontournable quelle est l'ampleur
économique du super bowl on estime qu'à
chaque année dans les villes qui
accueillent le super bowl que cela ait
un impact local de 500 millions $
on part avec ça c'est un stade de 65
mille personnes le billet sur le bief
papier le baril mais les 5000 $ mais la
moyenne à cause du marché secondaire
ce matin c'était à 9300 dollars us et on
peut payer 4500 pour rentrer dans les
pires billets jusqu'à 46 mille dollars
encore une fois en date de ce matin et
ça se voit et s'entend bien sur et puis
je pense que d'ici au match de dimanche
le prix va continuer d'augmenter
pourquoi parce que les preneurs aux
livres sont tellement serrés 15 ans
étaient favoris par un point et demi
c'était besoin de vraiment plus serré
donc un enjeu important
personne n'est vraiment favoris donc les
gens aiment ce genre de spectacle là où
on peut pas savoir qui va gagner et donc
il peut y avoir un vrai match
intéressante volanges le rang du vernis
tardif est parti de ce match là quelle
est la valeur commerciale de ce joueur
là cécile estimé aujourd'hui mais une
chose qui est clair c'est que on aura
rarement parler autant d'un joueur de
ligne à l'attaqué que dans ce cas ci et
je parle des états unis aussi le les
américains n'ont jamais vu un gars comme
laurent duverne établi alors évidemment
joueurs canadiens des jeux un peu
différent montréalais que joué son
football universitaire au canada mais
pas aux états unis à un niveau inférieur
c'est quand même taillé une place aux
états unis mais surtout graduée en
médecine alors là on a une rareté
une perle mais oui pour les médias
américains pour la ville de kenza
c'était mais aussi évidemment pour nous
au québec
on a affaire à un individu qui rallie
les gens autour de lui parce qu'il y eu
une histoire à raconter
et parce qu'il est grand sympathique
souriant gentil géant alors on est tous
impressionné par lui à l'ope les marques
qui vont vouloir ou les entreprises qui
vont vouloir s'associer à lui peuvent
aussi estimé qu'il ya une deuxième vie
alors rendue en italie ce médecin plus
tard donc on a affaire à quelqu'un qui
peut rester associé à notre marque
pendant de longues années
suivra alors sûr mais il va avoir toute
une baisse de salaire quand il va
devenir médecin mais ironiquement
aujourd'hui la ligue en plus de 8.3
millions $ wyss
c'est deux fois plus que son quart
arrière qui est la vedette du club qui
lui ne pas encore atteint le nombre
d'années nécessaires pour passer son
voeu à la banque mais le rendu de l'état
veut dire gagner sa vie il avait une
occasion de jouer au football pendant
cinq sets
8 heures il le fait j'espère qu'il va
jouer encore longtemps parce qu'il
demeure un ambassadeur une inspiration
pour les jeunes au québec
est-ce qu'il a déjà gagnée est-ce que sa
valeur est déjà très fort peu importe
que l'équipe que son équipe gagne ou ne
gagne pas absolument c'est sûr que c'est
un velours le de gagner deux matches
puis d'être champions du super bowl
sortir de là avec une bague tous les
jeunes joueurs de football dans leur vie
espère un jour atteindre le super bowl
c'est le rêve ultime
mais déjà on a mis les lumières sur lui
on réalise comment c'est un athlète
unique pour le canada et le québec
alors déjà sa valeur est survolté à
cause que son équipe s'est rendue
jusqu'au super bowl donc l'attention que
lui obtenu depuis deux jours c'est
inégalable c'est inestimable en termes
de valeur pour lui ça va coûter plus
cher aux partenaires qui vont vouloir
s'associer à lui clairement il y avait
un grand reportage sur le rang du vernis
tardive qu'on a diffusé jeudi soir à rdi
on voit que c'est un homme posé avec une
bonne tête sur les épaules
en même temps comment on gère le
marketing d'un garçon comme ça d' un
gars aussi intelligente brillante une
vedette comme ça mais d'abord une équipe
autour de lui
oui on peut appeler ce team laurent si
on veut we kiss composé de comptable
d'agents de conseiller évidemment tout
l'aspect soutien physique
et laurent dubernais tardif c'est un
gars qui est solide depuis ses années à
merrill c'est un groupe qui réfléchit
qui pense clairement connaît son
potentiel est capable de s'articuler de
l'exprimer
déjà il peut gérer lui même le propre
trafic commercial autour de lui mais en
plus si un agent qui est la peau négocié
des contrats et aussi faire des
alliances mais on a affaire à un quorum
en vue dans l'histoire du sport au
québec
donc il n'ya pas de vrai danger de
dérapage on n'a pas besoin des gens
comme vous qui avez beaucoup travaillé
dans le sport de l'encadrer comme
certains joie pour poteau pour autant
que la plupart des athlètes qui arrive
avec un talent brut lui c'est la
définition même étudiants-athlètes les
études au maximum et à inspirer les gens
lisent sommes motivés mais atteindre la
nfl et jouer régulier et atteindre le
super bowl c'est un exploit inégalé et
avoir monté sa propre fondation
également qu'il s'intéresse beaucoup à
l'art à l'éducation aux sports aux
études
il y vraiment à 28 ans il a réussi à
bâtir un modèle exceptionnel mais avec
sa fondation fait pas il fait partie des
athlètes qui ont vraiment une énorme
maturité à un jeune âge qui voit le
potentiel dans toutes les opportunités
de redonner d'être généreux de
contribuer à la communauté à la société
il le fait il travaille aussi
régulièrement dans la boulangerie de ses
parents oui alors il est vraiment
impliquée a tout les niveaux et la
fondation c'est important pour lui parce
qu'il se prépare une carrière pour deux
philanthropes et de redonner à des
jeunes pour les inspirer à rester aux
études et à poursuivre leur sport
préféré s'en inspire pour tous les
genres de votre barre mais laisse les
athlètes de toutes les formes
il ya une pizza son nom en plus sympa
reçoit ses parents qui ont la
boulangerie devancé l'allemand si je me
traîne laurent du vernis tardif ou là
laurent je ne sais trop la meilleure
pizza son nom bien merci beaucoup merci
jacques merci on va suivre ça vous
marque beaucoup d'intérêt bon matin moi
aussi